welcome to our house it's getting
towards the holidays and so what are you
going to eat for Thanksgiving and
Christmas if you're not going to eat me
well now that you finally have the
solution you've been waiting for Julie
and I are here we're going to cook up
all sorts of stuff great tasting stuff
some of the stuff is from our giant
cookbook and some new stuff too so what
we want to do is try to give you some
delicious plant-based options for the
holidays so you can eat your meal and
feel full and feel good so welcome to
our home and stay tuned so q1 you tell
us a little bit about what we have okay
so we're gonna use some of these
beautiful pristine veggies and fruits
direct from nature these from the
Calabasas farmers market and we have
some a mix of beautiful mushrooms wild
mushrooms
we have dill mint basil kale which is
favorite autumn rose grapes green apples
cilantro beets sprouted month and this
is just extraordinary violet cauliflower
we have corn spinach bananas rock
coconut
red potatoes pumpkin seeds cashews
almonds raw almonds right everything
wrong yeah
cranberries dates on the cheese chia
seeds a couple different kinds of
organic rice vegenaise very important
coconut oil apple cider vinegar organic
matzo sprouted flour red quinoa we know
we got a Celtic sea salt right here I'm
Celina naturally this stuff is great
yeah flour wood is free of flour and
here's some organic
Japanese so breadcrumbs so anyway stay
tuned and we're going to whip up some
surprises thanks for joining us why
don't you tell us a couple of the
recipes that we're going to make today
well we're gonna start with a couple
blended drinks because we always start
with a blend fill ourselves up so we're
not gal gene gorging ourselves on a lot
of heavy calorie for calorie heavy foods
so we're gonna make one two kinds of
blended drinks drinks one sort of a
cacao based shake type of drink and the
other one is more of a cleansing holiday
apple celery
go alright so